On October the fourth, 1957 the first satellite,
Sputnik I, was launched into space.
Although it burned up in the atmosphere three
months later, many satellites launched since
then have not, leaving us with a virtual junk
yard orbiting the earth.
Now those debris represent a real threat to
the television communications and GPS satellites,
not to mention the astronauts.
But luckily, the Swiss have a plan to clean
up space.
So I have come to Lausanne to figure out how
they are going to do it.
Most of the space junk orbiting earth is within
2000 kilometers of the earth’s surface.
There are over 22,000 objects larger than
this softball and over half a million larger
than this marble.
Now all of the orbiting debris is going about
seven to eight kilometers per second, but
since the objects are moving relative to one
another the average speed of a collision is
about 10 kilometers per second.
And an object this size going 10 kilometers
per second has about the same impact as a
midsize car going nearly 200 kilometers per
hour.
That is enough force to destroy any satellite
in orbit.
As a veteran of four space flights, Swiss
astronaut Claude Nicollier knows the dangers
first hand.
>> Only the large debris are tracked.
By radar we know the orbit exactly and sometimes
we have to be a small change in the orbiter
characteristics that our space ship, the space
shuttle...
>> Space shuttle Endeavor...
>>... because it is foreseen that next day
or two days later we are going to have a close
approach with a debris, such that NASA was
not feeling to good about that and we translated
our orbits so to make that distance a little
bit larger.
>> Fortunately, to date, there haven’t been
any serious collisions with manned spaced
craft.
But in 2009 a single crash between two satellites
added a whopping 2000 new pieces of debris.
>> If we don’t do anything, space will become
soon inaccessible because of the large amount
of debris and the high risk of collision.
>> So the Swiss, determined to do something
about that problem, are extending their clean
country reputation into outer space.
>> The Swiss space center has launched a program
called Clean Space One that is a demonstrator
of the capability to remove debris.
And the idea is to go and to remove one of
two satellites from Switzerland.
>> One of these two satellites is appropriately
named Swiss Cube.
>> Swiss Cube is a small satellite which you
see.
This is a one to one model.
So this is in the right scale.
It belongs to Switzerland.
So we had to do something about this.
>> You can’t have Swiss junk just floating
around in space.
>> No.
No.
That is not acceptable.
>> So the mission for Clean Space One is a
proof of concept that a janitor satellite
can be sent into space to grab a piece of
space junk—in this case Swiss Cube and bring
it back into the atmosphere where it will
burn up.
To rendezvous with the space junk, the small
janitor needs an incredibly efficient engine.
Working on the challenge is Professor Herbert
Shea, an expert in micro mechanics.
>> This is your propulsion system.
>> This is our propulsion system.
Little silicone micro machine chips.
We use something called electro propulsion,
which allows you to emit single atoms with
a ... that are electrically charged and use
an electric field to accelerate them out.
So you are not burning them.
You are emitting your propellant.
And that is what many small satellites use,
but nothing has been, to date, been able to
make something this small.
So we do zero to 60 miles an hour in a about
three days.
But laughable as it, indeed, seems to all
of us, because there is no friction in space,
or negligible friction, then if we wait six
months, we have a huge change in speed.
And that is how the mission will be done.
>> Once propelled into the correct orbit,
the next challenge is to grab the space junk,
an object tumbling around uncontrollably without
creating more debris.
>> Our idea is to use a very compliant system.
Kind of think of an octopus arm.
An octopus arm is very soft, but it can grab
any strange shape and wrap around it and hold
it.
And we will have a grabber that looks, in
a very ... but that real one will be more
sophisticated.
But it looks like this.
So it is basically very, very soft elastomer.
I will turn it on in a minute.
You can see how soft it is.
And the idea is this will be rolled up so
it doesn't take up much room.
You get into... and it will have 10 of these
in a series.
You get into space, you unroll it.
And then these things can open when you turn
the voltage on.
You are able to open this and you turn the
voltage off and it wraps it around and it
holds the satellite.
>> Is this going to be a little bit like those
games where you are trying to pick up a stuffed
toy in the arcade and drop it somewhere?
Is it going to be like that?
>> Essentially, yes.
>> Because those games... those games can
be incredibly frustrating with those little
arms.
>> They are built to be frustrating.
>> Whereas this, this is built to be ...
>> This is built to succeed.
>> Can I ask?
Has anyone ever successfully gone up and grabbed
a piece of space junk and gotten rid of it?>>
To my knowledge, no.
It has never been done before.
>> And it grabs on.
>> Ambitious as it may sound, the Swiss know
how vast this junk yard is.
So their ultimate aims are more modest.
>> Hopefully starting in, say, 2020 to do
systematic removal of the large debris at
the rate of five or more per year in order
to contain the increase of the debris density
in lower earth orbit.
Then space will continue becoming accessible.
Of course, the exposure to the space environment
is a wonderful thing.